mystery wire wow it's hard to
fathom that that is a balloon that is
something it's fascinating it's what it
is i want mr wire to keep going
that was riveting ted this is uh this is
a big drop today
big time you told us about it we knew
this was gonna happen right 90s this
weekend a lot of people loved it but
some of you were also emailing me going
hey it's too soon let's cool things off
and you got it right live look outside
again from our other tower cam this is
on the far west side of the valley
red rock station casino tower cam
looking towards the east clear skies
however
we still have a little bit of a hazy out
there so moderate air quality
mulberry ash and alder this is the
pollen report reporting high readings
those winds didn't help kicking up that
pollen but at least the winds have
calmed down
temperatures outside 77 in centennial
hills summerlin at 70 even new
neighborhoods here to show you downtown
double sevens for you along with nellis
aliante 74 the east side coming in
closer to 80. 78 green valley and
henderson year at 79 roads ranch and
mountains edge both at 76 southern
highlands included
73 for seven hills 79 for a prompt in
boulder city at 75
77 for prim so here's our radar network
clear skies even in southern california
to arizona and even in utah
so here's our drive-in movie forecast
guys you ready for this
tonight's freaky feature cooking with
chris matthews
he's not here not here all right so
rated g
forecast approved by all the all
audiences by ted sherry nate sally and
ashley rated g okay
but look hey there's loftus and denise
is there
d nice view look at those cars i give
you the nice cars okay
let's race chris matthews he's his bug
is over here
all right here's how it looks tonight 73
degrees at 8 p.m 9 p.m 70 67 at 10 p.m
clear skies and again winds should stay
light so yeah if you want to do
something outdoors perfect night for
that as temperatures will still be
nice and mild this evening so here's
your eight on the eight your eight day
forecast the place here in las vegas so
you only find your eight day forecast
85 for tomorrow and then the numbers go
up
drop again on friday a little breezy on
thursday closer to 90 for the weekend
we'll have to watch out for some wind on
the weekend
and then next week we'll still stay in
those high 80s partly
sunny by wednesday next week denise over
to you
ted not only are you the most accurate
but you have fun with your graphics and
we appreciate that
this is